ukraine came to the general assembly
arguing that russian aggression is a
violation of the u.n charter as well as
a deadly existential threat they have
come to the ukrainian soil
not only to kill some of us not only to
shift our cause and priorities
they have come to deprive ukraine of the
very right to exist
here russia has no veto power just the
power to make its case even in the face
of enormous opposition
your refusal to support today's draft
resolution is a vote for a peaceful
ukraine free from radicalism and
neo-nazism
in the end only four member states sided
with the russians 141 voting in favor of
the resolution deploring the military
operation
today the world has spoken with a clear
united voice
together
the vast majority of the world has
condemned russia's unprovoked
unjustified unconscionable war
we have deplored belarus for allowing
its territory to be used to facilitate
this aggression
35 countries abstain from voting among
them china india and south africa the
resolution that we have considered today
does not create an environment
conducive for diplomacy
dialogue and mediation
however the united arab emirates which
had abstained on a similar resolution in
the security council came out in favor
right now we recognize that this
resolution adopted here today is a
necessary signal of where we we need to
be going
resigning ourselves to a cycle of
perpetual violence and sanctions that
only adds to the suffering of civilians
diminishes us all
under international law matters of peace
and security are the purview of the
security council but the council invoked
a rarely used provision of the u.n
charter to get around the russian veto
and call for this special emergency
session of the general assembly its
outcome according to sponsors shows
russia's isolation on the international
stage
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations